so when members of a real company go to
work they have to do it undercover it's
a matter of staying alive
shells are stacked under a gnarly tree
the mortar revealed in the bushes
for the Russians have eyes in the sky
okay Yuri was a carpenter now he's the
Commander in a village just outside the
city of bakmut here in Bahamut is the
hottest point right on the right 24
hours
per per day
we have attacks on our positions
this area is a veritable Kill Zone raked
by artillery and Small Arms fire and
Yuri knows the Russians will reply
I think we need to go down like a game
of Hide and Seek the unit Retreat to the
bunker it's a place to sleep and store
their arms our enemy have many many
weapons and artillery we don't have a
lot of artillery we have
most of the times we have problems with
tanks and artillery on the
Russians began to Shell the area a
speedy response to Ukrainian fire a real
company was stuck Underground
up oh that was close yeah that was close
maybe closer outgunned by the enemy
they've been making their own weapons
here off the shelf drones with
explosives attached I asked my friend
they are a pilot pilot on the
quadrocopter yeah and I asked double
press and drop a present in the this
hole and yeah okay we have success here
they target a Russian gun placement but
there is a problem everyone has access
to a drone but Russians now use these
two positions an example and they
they're learning from you they're
learning and they yeah
after the Russian barrage we returned to
the surface the commander Keen to take
us to a town called solidar
every single building has been damaged
or destroyed like a scene from the
Second World War
like a Stalingrad because we have maybe
90 percent of buildings are demolished
yeah yeah black star Stalingrad we have
we call them solegrad
but it's it's so dark
it's a grim joke in a region where the
ukrainians are losing ground their
troops now building trenches around the
city of bakmut but the commander says he
isn't worried the Russians are using
mercenaries from a private military
company called Wagner and they're paying
a terrible price
videos
the ukrainians provided us with these
pictures
the dead they claim are from Wagner
who've done some of their recruiting in
Russian prisons how do you know that the
Russians have been using Wagner
mercenaries here traffic
[Music]
profession
life at the front isn't easy and for
many ukrainians it's also short
commanders told us they are suffering
serious casualties in back move
it's a war of extreme brutality and it
comes at an incalculable cost
John Sparks Sky News in eastern Ukraine